hold the dark is a 2018 Netflix original
thriller movie the film features wolves
and sheep's clothing wolves in human
clothing and there is a lot to unpack
from its plot throughout this video I
will be discussing hold the dark and
full detail and there will be heavy
spoilers the film is definitely worth
checking out if you're a fan of
thrillers and the piece stands is one of
the best Netflix original movies that is
currently on the platform without the
way I'm definition and I ruin the movie
so you don't have to we follow Russell
core as he investigates the
disappearance of a boy that has been
taken by wolves early on in the film
core discovers the boys frozen corpse
but that doesn't mean the case is a
closed one we learn that the boy has
been strangled by his mother Medora
Medora escapes the strong arm of the law
and with her husband Byrne murder many
police officers and escape in the film's
clothes they meet up and share a kiss
and it's here where the film's big
questions begin to rear their heads most
questions online circle around the
meaning of the wolf mask it definitely
is the movie's most intriguing aspect
and has a lot of symbology to it the
mask makes its first appearance when
Medora tries to seduce Russell she
forces him to nearly strangle her to
death which symbolically kills a human
persona and allows her to be able to
embrace her wolf mentality in the latter
part of the film learn to dons the same
mask when committing many murders and
this is a way for him to assume medoras
lupine spirit masks can often force us
to change our personalities in several
ways and they are used in pop culture to
symbolise the donning or wearing of a
different personality psychologists have
debated for decades whether the mask
that Batman wears is his true face and
many have stated that Bruce Wayne is in
fact the mask that he dons in order to
act and appear in a certain way similar
to this Medora is a facade that hides
the true face of the world
this dual identity could explain why she
contacts Russell early on to help her
track down her son and she appears to
have a split personality disorder whilst
neither characters or worlds themselves
they certainly possess the mind state
that they are local Indians Warren
Russell that they are possessed by wolf
spirits and in the real world this is a
condition known as species dysphoria the
condition makes the patient believe that
they were born the wrong species and
symptoms include believing that you have
phantom wings or an animal soul that has
been reincarnated as a human we also
learn that burn and Medora are in fact
siblings and whilst we don't get a
backstory we can draw conclusions from
their incestuous relationship that may
have had huge effects on them
psychologically their behavior too
explains why Russell was the only
survivor of their brutal murder spree
Russell wrote a book called a year among
them which documented his time with the
canine creatures able to interact with
them and a kindred spirit the to spare
him because of his respect for their
species but why did they do it well we
never get concrete answers as to why
Medora murdered her son Russell believed
that she wanted to spare him from a
lifetime of darkness both in reality as
the region he lived in had a nighttime
starting at 3:30 p.m. but also the
darkness that he will inherit from his
other parents whether the two survived
we will never know but we do bear
witness to them escorting their sons
coffin and being followed by wolves
whether they were killed by them or they
joined the pack is up to the viewer but
I agree with the latter in my eyes they
have became the wolf so what did you
interpret from hold the dark comment
below and let me know and if you enjoyed
this video then please like it and
subscribe to my channel I create content
like this weekly and they'll definitely
be something on here that you love if
you're a fan of film make sure you check
out my maniac and the explain theory
linked at the end of this one and thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]
you
[Music]